ble C podcast man we already uh first of
all just did an amazing interview with
Maya the dawn she's on tour with Flo
Milly right now hot commodity is out
everywhere there might be a deluxe we
don't know coming soon but go support
her and she could wrap her ass off
period period so we just G to get right
to it man come
on
uhhuh Big M what we doing cab low 50
Cent come on oh yeah uh
yeah uh he want to have a baby Bonnie
Baby Be A Millionaire uh uh I ain't in
no pillow talking on no late night
texting you got to drop a bag if you
want my attention you begging for a
taste and my taste is expensive diamonds
on my neck cuz I like the reflection
uh-huh can you it for me I like Seline
King you Supreme Christian do you me I
want Roan I no school yard Crush give me
the moon in the Stars cuz the world not
enough yeah and you keep [__] with
these B hoes cuzz they cheap you ain't
never been selective Out The Company You
Keep don't be with just anybody that's
never been my style I don't politic
[__] can't even get a smile I ain't
getting paid you won't see me in the
function a buck from the jump I ain't
[__] with assumptions come correct
with me and my [__] is going laugh at
you on a different caliber can I deal
withes righted bottom bag I'm a well
paid Dawn new two se but the top four
gone ban in a clip get your top ped off
touch a couple Keys move like R off uh
go get in my feelings I'm in my bag more
and I don't argue with women without a
passport type of [__] I get anything
that she asked for don't never got to
say much see the way my bag talk the VAC
beds in the be you five in chills in my
dress for see through I know I said I
want you that don't mean that I need you
I'm In My Own Lane I ain't worried about
what she do he [__] a broke [__] cuz
that's not how I maneuver if my
heartbreak is getting fixed by My
Jeweler he play about my money go Stacks
blue hunds I get it if I want to give a
[__] about a budget [__] yeah oh I'mma
keep going I'm keep going going keep
going oh yeah uh uh big down Big D Big D
red bottoms on my feet like I'm dancing
with the devil I just let the Jeweler
drop the BS on the bezel poters on my
face got my kitty saying hello never say
I love you can't have [__] sping
special [__] love attention so they ly
say they [__] me put it on my life can
let a broke [__] touch me please come
get your man he be all up in my DM
[__] really grow up just to be
somebody's be walking to the function
and some you can't afford this and I'm
flying private baby you can't board this
[__] in my damn butt I ignore we ain't
talking about that bag then that
conversation boring uh have a baby momy
yeahoo have a baby mommy baby uh have a
baby baby oh yeah big oh my God that's
how we do one take [__] come on
H commodity out right now my dog I'm a
rapper honey hey appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG